[Music]
uh
uh
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
good morning my name is dan mason
welcome to my youtube channel firstly a
moment of silence for all of those that
haven't subscribed
to go over and subscribe smack that
subscribe button and make sure to turn
that notifications bell on
cool alrighty that excessive intro
sequence is not reality
i dramatically affected a mundane
morning to exhibit the idea of using
sound and music to elevate the boring
and make it more exciting
filmmaking is really quite special and
it's a lot easier than it seems maybe
i'm just weird but
i remember when i started out i was
really scared of the industry i was
really scared to pick up the camera and
step into the filmmaking world i just
thought i wasn't cool enough i wasn't
smart enough creative enough or trendy
enough
but when i started i just immediately
stopped caring about all that [ __ ]
and the process of creating these films
just took over and completely engulfed
me
and now 12 years between failures and
successes as a film director later
i'm able to make the films i want to
make with rad people
and get paid to do so and with this new
series creator hacks
brought to you by epidemic sound most
innovative and user-friendly sound and
music library out there i'll be doing a
once a month masterclass on the realm of
filmmaking to help you advance your
filmmaking career
to kick things off this year i'm going
to teach you about the most crucial yet
the most overlooked part of the
filmmaking process whether you're making
instagram reels or feature films and
that's the skill
of sound and music with the following
six talking points you'll be a sound and
music professional
that sounds ridiculous but you will
within 10 minutes we will discuss
psychoacoustics the magic in music
diegetic
and non-diegetic sound recording sound
for your videos
how to source great sound and music and
lastly how to perfect your sound and
music in post-production
sound is so powerful that it can
transform human behavior four years ago
the african country kenya was
experiencing massive segregation as they
had 42 different tribes
with unique beliefs so myself and a
group of creators flew to every tribe to
record natural sounds from their
ceremonies
and compiled them into a rhythmic new
age anthem for kenya this soundtrack
united the tribes within kenya because
no matter what your belief or language
music emotionally evokes connection
globally
we can all feel it but we can't
communicate it with dialogue
i've made many films that use sound and
music as the vehicle to drive the story
and that is why i'm super excited to
jump into the session with you number
one
psychoacoustics this is the scientific
study of sound perception
and audiology how humans perceive
various sounds studying the
psychological responses associated with
sound including noise
speech and music and to showcase the
importance of sound and music i've put
together something really funny
just to visually showcase how different
a scene can be perceived related to the
sound or music
you attach to it just look at what
happens when i take the scene from fight
club and utilize the soundtrack from
footloose
[Music]
or this scene from titanic with the
soundtrack of frozen
let it go
[Music]
this comedic scene in the hangover with
the soundtrack from dead silence
a dramatic love scene in the notebook
with the soundtrack from jaws
point two why music is magic what is it
exactly about music that allows it to
evoke emotion
unlike any other sense listening to
music our pupils dilate and our pulse
and blood pressure rise
music activates large areas of the brain
including the auditory
motor and limbic system researchers have
demonstrated that music actually
triggers the brain to release dopamine
the feel-good chemical
into parts of the brain that have been
associated with the response to
pleasurable stimuli
you can almost say that music is the
completely natural drug of happiness
hearing an old song can take you back
decades in the blink of an eye almost
like a time machine
it turns out that music also stimulates
the prefrontal cortex of the brain
very familiar pieces of music act like
soundtracks to trigger a very specific
mental movie that starts playing in our
head
implicit unintentional memories like
this are durable as well as
emotional it is such strong connection
that music can awaken
alzheimer's patients and is used to
improve their lives
number three diegetic and non-diegetic
sound diegetic sound is a source
which has a sound on screens there are
noises which haven't been
edited in for example me speaking to
camera or banging this bottle
on the desk non-diegetic sound is a
noise which does not have a source on
the screen
like now i could add in the sound of a
train station next door
or ambience of being inside of an
airport
or in a stadium but not just ambient
sounds it could also be music voice over
or sound effects non-diegetic sounds are
often used to add drama to moments that
would be silent without it
therefore diegetic sounds are super
important to capture while shooting
quality is super important here and i
have a few tricks and tips to be able to
record great quality sound on the cheap
number four recording sound for your
videos sounds and dialogue must
perfectly sync with the actions in a
film without delay and must sound the
way they look
if a sound doesn't quite match the
action on screen the action itself
isn't nearly as believable one way to
achieve believable high quality sounds
is to use original clips rather than
relying
solely on sound libraries for sound
effects when recording sound make sure
to
first identify any
how problems echo is in your room i like
to clap and find out where the echo is
coming from
[Music]
all rooms are dynamic and some parts of
your room may be better suited for
recording than others
but just because there might be some
echo in your room doesn't mean you
should find a different room to record
in it might still work
cover up hard surfaces like walls with
books
add a carpet to the floor or in my case
astroturf to absorb the sound
block any gaps to a larger room with a
thick material if you have some budget
to spare get some professional foam to
absorb the sound or if not you can make
use of
egg cartons they really do work and with
some creativity you can
make something pretty rad and if you're
only doing audio i know that the sounds
and
looks ridiculous but you can make use of
a blanket to cover the camera
dead in the space and create really
crisp audio
the truth is that the quality of your
audio is greatly determined on the type
of microphone you use
for recording high quality audios to
choose the right microphone most people
make the mistake of relying solely on
the built-in microphone on their camera
but i'd suggest you invest in an
external microphone like one of the
following dependents on the kind of film
you want to make
the desktop microphone which sounds
something like this
which you can use for shooting podcasts
voice overs
one location gaming or news channels
lipo microphones there's many different
options of these i'm currently using the
small one these are what the older ones
look like
and they also make one for your cell
phone lipo microphones are great for
shooting talking headshots on locations
that may be loud as they're very
directional and
yeah i just love them they are great a
simple shotgun microphone which is what
i use mainly
it's great for ambience for shooting on
location
it's the most common filmmakers
microphone but you do need to be
vigilant when it comes to noises you
can't control like wind
when shooting with this microphone make
sure that you turn down what's known as
the preamp which is the internal sound
within your camera
to as low as possible some cameras can
go the whole way to zero but with canon
you can go just before
and then rather turn up the volume on
your microphone and this will reduce the
hissing sound
another thing to add to your kids is a
set of headphones to make sure you can
listen to the sound before you record it
if you don't have a set of headphones
make sure that your levels
on your camera aren't clipping above
zero this is indicated by
moving into the red and lastly something
a little bit more professional which is
an external recorder
which sounds something like this this
piece of gear is a little bit more
professional it's for recording multiple
channels of audio
portably and then one last tip is when
you're on location make sure you roll on
what's called a buzz track that's just
30 seconds or a minute
of dead silence this will really help
you when blending clips of audio
the next thing we need to consider in
any room is the source of
noises for instance take a look around
your office space and try and identify
anything that's making a noise there are
plenty of things in a room that generate
noise here are some common noise makers
around the office environment
servers a banging window fans and lights
there's not really a lot you can do for
fans or lights other than turn them off
and
most people can't control their
thermostat remember that it's far easier
to remove noises in post
when there is a consistent sound so if
you can't turn something off make sure
it's on the whole way through the
recording
the other source of noise is exterior
weather conditions
traffic noisy co-workers or loud office
space
if you can't enforce a way to make them
stop like
it's best that you rather come in early
in the morning or do what i do and just
stay super late at night now let's move
into how to source great sound and music
for your videos
legally these are non-diegetic sounds
and are usually very difficult to source
in high quality or when it comes to
music
finding soundtracks that are solid as
well as not overused like with most
sound libraries i work with epidemic
sound and have for a long time now as i
believe in their product so much i would
swear by them as the best music and
sound library out there the team at
epidemic and myself share a common love
and appreciation for sound and music and
video actually before i continue if you
don't own an epidemic sound account yet
you can go to the top link in my
description and get yourself an account
right now
if not you can skip the section and go
to this timestamp
cool so the main thing i absolutely love
about epidemic is not just the efficient
interface
but through the emotive music made by
real musicians and furthermore
is the ability to edit their artists
tracks with the use of stems
as i as a filmmaker can craft a track
that feels unique
i make use of premiere pro but the same
process or formula can be used for any
editing software
once you've downloaded all your stems
pull them right to the beginning of your
timeline so that you get a time stamp
mark
from here all the stems will slot into
place perfectly timed
then what i like to do is just listen to
the dialogue as well as look at the
visuals
and then slowly crafted pulling back on
the melody or pushing in the bass
or pulling back on the percussion you
can make it work for whatever film
you're making
then when it comes to the sound library
it's packed with all kinds of sound
again if you support me go over and
support epidemic sound
linked below then lastly perfecting your
sound in post
okay i'm going to make use of premiere
pro to show you the quickest way to
improve your audio
pull in adaptive noise reduction as well
as parametric equalizer
you don't need to touch the noise
reduction you can just leave it as is
click the parametric equalizer where we
can do some simple fine tunings
pull the l on the far left side slightly
up
around plus 20 master gain then for the
mid tones here on number three we'll
drag it down ever so slightly and then
for the high tones on the right hand
side
just drag it up here slightly not as
much as the low end on the left hand
side
the correct levels depend on the exact
audio file you are using
but the line should look more or less
like this most importantly
use your ears and play it back a few
times until it sounds
just right that's the quickest way to
improve your audio in premiere pro
and that's it for today's creator hacks
please send through any questions or
suggestions that you would like me to
cover in the episodes to come also
please comment below if there was
something that you just didn't
understand and would like me to explain
it again and write
thank you so much for all your support
and i'm just so excited about this year
ahead together and remember to like this
video
turn on your notifications bell
subscribe so that you don't miss next
week's video other than that don't
forget
you're awesome brew and i'll see you
next week
you